estamos viniendo la casa que nació mi
casa era de madera
es esta casa
abajo vivíamos nosotros Salomón un judío
sefardín de Estambul guarda Mil
recuerdos de estas calles su antiguo
barrio balat era poblado mayormente por
judíos griegos y armenios hace un siglo
de ellos ahora ya no queda nadie ya me
iba a irme cuando tenía 14 15 años
Mira hijo han decomites del pan y
bebites la agua no la dejes
este país de estudio Aquí naciste y aquí
te vas a levantarte
y bueno que no me fui de aquí en la
actualidad en Turquía quedan alrededor
de 14.000 sefardis los descendientes de
los judíos que fueron expulsados de
España durante el siglo XV algunos de
los pocos asentados en Estambul hablan
en Ladino un idioma que ahora está a
punto de desaparecer el periódico shalom
lucha para mantener vivo el idioma
la siguiente generación a la mía ya no
entiende demasiado Aladino y ya no lo
habla esto significa que en máximo 20 30
o 40 años el Ladino desaparecerá lo que
nosotros hacemos Es intentar que esta
desaparición tarde lo máximo posible
en la familia de Rafael está
desaparición está latente a diferencia
de él y de su mujer sus hijas no hablan
y entienden en Ladino desde la zona
década España y Portugal entregan la
ciudadanía los sefardíes y como muchos
otros miembros de la comunidad Él y su
familia son ahora además de turcos
portugueses él dice que quiere quedarse
morirse en Estambul las nuevas
generaciones quieren marcharse de
Turquía hay muchas familias que se van
mi hija comía no se fueron a Portugal
a portugués por caminar y por Mirar los
sefardíes en Estambul aceptan que en
unas décadas desaparecerán pero su
idioma su pasado y sus 500 años de
historia en las orillas del bósforo se
niegan a disiparse